نعود مشاهدينا الى الخبر العاجل الذي
اشرنا له في بدايه النشره حيث اكد الجيش
الامريكي ان المسير الايرانيه التي قام
باسقاطها حاولت استطلاع قاعده للقوات
الامريكيه في شمال شرق سوريا اذا الجيش
الامريكي يؤكد ان الطائره المسيره
الايرانيه التي قام باسقاطها كانت طائره
تحاول استطلاع قاعده له في شمال شرق سوريا
هذه هي المره الاولى التي يعلن فيها الجيش
الامريكي اسقاط طائره مسيره تحاول التجسس
على قاعدته وهذه سوره الطائره المسيره
الايرانيه التي قام الجيش الامريكي
باستهدافها واسقاطها هذه المسيره حسب قوات
الجيش الامريكي كانت تحاول استطلاع قاعده
للجيش الامريكي في شمال شرق سوريا طبعا
هذه الصوره نشرها الجيش الامريكي واكد انه
تم اسقاطها لدى
محاوله تجسسها على القاعده التي يمتلكها
شمال سوريا
وهذه لحظه اسقاط المسيره حسب الجيش
الامريكي اذا الجيش الامريكي ينشر صوره
الطائره المسيره الايرانيه ولحظه اسقاطها
ويؤكد انها كانت تحاول التجسس على قاعدته
في شمال سوريا